vamos a ver si podemos saber cuánto es
cuatro tercios menos un quinto
si creen que pueden hacerlo los animo a
que pausa en el vídeo y lo intenten
cuando vemos estas fracciones nos damos
cuenta de que tienen diferentes
denominadores y no es obvio cómo restar
un quinto de cuatro tercios cuando
tenemos estos denominadores diferentes y
la clave está en reescribir estas
fracciones para que tengan el mismo
denominador como hacemos para saber cuál
es el denominador que debemos usar debe
ser un múltiplo común para el 3 y el 5 y
debe ser el mínimo común múltiplo para
el 3 y el 5 entonces como lo calculamos
podemos empezar con el mayor de estos
números en este caso es el 5 y vamos a
revisar sus múltiplos hasta que
encontremos uno que sea exactamente
divisible entre 3 entonces 5 no es
divisible entre 3 y es no es divisible
entre 3 15 si es divisible entre 3 15 es
igual a 3 por 5 así que podemos
reescribir estas dos fracciones como
algo sobre 15 cuánto es cuatro tercios y
lo queremos escribir como algo sobre 15
para obtener el 15 a partir del 3 en el
denominador tenemos
y multiplicar por 5 cómo multiplicamos
el denominador por 5 si no queremos
cambiar el valor de la fracción tenemos
que multiplicar el numerador por 5
también 4 por 5 es igual a 20 entonces
cuatro tercios es igual a 20 y 15 a
bosch ahora como escribimos un quinto
como algo sobre 15 tenemos 15 en el
denominador y para pasar del 5 al 15
tenemos que multiplicar por 3 y si
multiplicamos el denominador por 3
también tenemos que multiplicar el
numerador por 31 por 3 es igual a 3
entonces podemos reescribir cuatro
tercios menos un quinto como 2015 ambos
menos 315 abós y ahora podemos resolver
esto directamente cuál es el resultado
bueno sabemos que va a ser un cierto
número de 15 a bosch tenemos 20 15 a vos
y le vamos a quitar 315 a vos entonces
vamos a tener un resultado en 15 a vos
tenemos que 20 menos 3 es igual a 17 15
a vos y si queremos reescribir esto como
un número mixto vemos que el 15 cabe en
el 17 una vez y nos quedan 215 a vos
entonces tenemos 1 y 2 15 a vos
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
queremos saber cuánto es siete décimos
- cinco octavos y los ánimos que pausa
en el vídeo para que resuelvan esto por
ustedes mismos como vimos antes tenemos
diferentes denominadores y necesitamos
reescribir estas fracciones con un
denominador común para que podamos
restar entonces cuál es el múltiplo
común entre 18 y queremos encontrar el
mínimo común múltiplo no es forzoso pero
podemos encontrarlo para hacer esto más
sencillo bueno vamos a empezar con el
mayor de los denominadores que en este
caso es el 10 y luego vamos a encontrar
sus múltiplos y ver si son divisibles
entre 8 10 no es exactamente divisible
entre 8 20 tampoco 30 tampoco 40 si lo
es 40 es un múltiplo de 10 y también de
8 40 es el mínimo común múltiplo de 10 y
8 podemos reescribir estas dos
fracciones como algo sobre 40 y vamos a
tener algo sobre 40
- algo sobre 40 y esto que es igual
entonces siete décimos es que sobre
cuarenta bueno para ir del 10 al 40 en
el denominador tuvimos que multiplicar
por 4 así que debemos hacer lo mismo con
el numerador multiplicar 7 por 4 y es
igual a 28 entonces 7 decimos es lo
mismo que 28 40 bosch y vamos a hacer lo
mismo con la otra fracción para ir del 8
al 40 en el denominador tenemos que
multiplicar por 5 8 por 5 es 40 y si
multiplicamos el denominado por 5
también tenemos que multiplicar el
numerador por 5 5 por 5 es igual a 25
entonces 7 decimos menos 5 octavos es lo
mismo que 28 40 bosch menos 25 40 bosch
y esto tiene sentido el resultado va a
ser un cierto número de 40 vos si tengo
28 40 vos y resto 25 40 vos cuántos me
quedan me quedan tres cuarenta vos 28 40
vos menos 25 40 vos es igual a 3
y terminamos siete décimos menos cinco
octavos es igual a 340 vos